what should we do with historical
figures for top 10 videos I'm hoping you
can help answer that question on today's
episode of lunch and earn soma getting a
lot of requests from you guys and I was
on google hangout recent with Christina
my video editor and she was asking and
you guys have been asking to do more
historical figures Julius Caesar and
Cleopatra and people who we have no
video content of to do the top tens and
all of our top 10s has been video
footage right we do a little bit of an
intro then we cut to them and then back
to us and so I've been struggling with
how can we do a top 10 series that is
educational that's informative but not
boring and you know there's a bunch of
quotes from these people and I thought
you know I could read some other people
could read some but the quotes are short
four seconds ten seconds long and I feel
just stringing together quotes won't
work and I don't want to just narrate
something to have it Superboy and so I'm
gonna ask mark his thoughts and I'd also
love to know your thoughts to how to be
able to incorporate this because of been
in so much feedback on it so what do you
think well it's funny I think when when
you start it with your channel with the
model in the Masters you started by
voicing these pieces and doing that yep
so so are you thinking about moving back
to that potentially or you want to
really get away from that I'm open to
ideas I'm open to ideas well i think you
know when you're dealing with anything
that you don't have footage for you need
to manufacture some kind of content so
the ideas are there the thoughts are
there the like you know the quotes tho
tho you can write a script you can have
a voice that's there but what are you
going to see how is this going to be
something that's more interesting you
know your greatest asset other than the
great team of video producers you have
behind you is the community right so so
having a community who interacts is is
huge so i would say go out to the
community potentially like you can have
your team create the content and then
you can select or people can volunteer
to maybe record it you know you can have
people from all over the world in all
walks of life coming together to share
key points kind of like David
Letterman's old top 10 list now I guess
what do you say that gives you 45
seconds or a minute of content
so potentially you could also then you
could record yourself how about that you
could record yourself watching this
stuff and then we can see I like
watching Evan at home and I like
watching Evan on vacation or on your
honeymoon and stuff I like watching you
react to stuff I think that's a lot of
fun so have the stuff written get the
community to to film the stuff at you
know you have all these great
opportunities to have all these shouts
out to different people they're all
coming together for something and then I
want to see you react to us doing it
cool I like that idea I want to know
what you guys think so if we're doing a
piece on Julius Caesar as an example
would you want to do a recording of it
and be part of the video and then have
me potential react to it and on top of
that are there other ideas that you have
on how to make a Julius Caesar top 10
video interesting leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out second idea Oh second idea get
you in a julius caesar hat okay good
listen a hat makes every video better so
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon